welcome back everyone this is part three
in our series on supervised sentiment
analysis this screencast is going to
focus on the stanford sentiment tree
bank let me start with a quick project
overview uh the associated paper is
social sochart all 2013.
i think this paper is a kind of model of
open science at this website here you
can see the full code uh all the data of
course as well as an api that will let
you try out new examples and kind of
interact with the core models that are
motivated in the paper
it's a sentence level corpus it's got
about 11 000 sentences in total and all
of those sentences are originally from
rotten tomatoes so they are sentences
from movie reviews uh the sentences
themselves were originally released by
pang and lee in 2005 it's kind of
classic data set and what the sst did
was expand the data set by labeling not
only the full sentences
but all of the sub constituents
according to a kind of traditional parse
syntactic parse of each of the examples
and those are all crowd source labels so
what this means is that we have vastly
more supervision signals all throughout
the structure of these examples than we
would get from the original or we just
had a single sentiment label for the
entire
sentence the labels themselves in the
underlying corpus are five-way label
labels that are extracted from workers
slider responses so there's kind of
an initial layer of aggregation they
made a slider choice they were all
grouped together into five labels and
then we are going to work with a
formulation that is even more collapsed
down to ternary sentiment i'll return to
that a bit later
the fully labeled tree thing is one of
the really exciting aspects of this
corpus that we will be able to take
advantage of especially during training
so the way that worked is there were
parses this is a simple
constituent parse of a sent the sentence
nlu is enlightening and as i've
indicated here we have labels in that
space zero through four
on all of the lexical items nlu is an
enlightening as well as the altis sub
constituents in this phrase so you can
see that is is neutral but since
enlightening is positive the whole verb
phrase is enlightening is positive
we can say that nlu is neutral but in
the context of this sentence the overall
contribution is a highly positive one so
label four on the root
um
i in the first screencast for this unit
i motivated sentiment analysis with some
cases that i thought were kind of
difficult from a syntactic point of view
this is one of them they said it would
be great i love how this is being
handled we can see that down here be
great is kind of clearly positive but by
the time we have filtered that through
this report they said just kind of
displacing the sentiment onto another
agent the speaker is not necessarily
endorsing the claim of greatness uh what
we get in the end is more like a neutral
sentiment i think that's interesting and
we can extend that even further right
these are actual predictions from the
model that's motivated in the underlying
paper if we take that constituent that i
just showed you
and can join it with they were wrong
which is clearly negative uh strikingly
the model is able to figure out that the
overall sentiment is determined by this
second clause here and assigned
negatives to the entire thing despite
the fact that there are obviously
sub-constituents in here that are
positive that's exactly the kind of
mixing that i think is correct for how
language works in the domain of
sentiment and it's kind of encouraging
to see that this model is able to
capture at least some aspects of it
here's a similar case that i think is
pretty good as well although maybe not
as strikingly positive in the end here
i've just changed from the previous
example they were they were wrong till
they were right
it knows that right is correct and it
seems to get that this is kind of middle
of the scale i might hope this was a
three or a four but i think that still
we're seeing some interesting
interactions between what's happening in
sub-constituents in these examples and
the prediction that's made at the root
level so it's very encouraging
there are a bunch of ways that you can
formulate the sst task kind of the raw
one that comes from the paper would be a
five-way classification problem where
we'd have these numerical labels here
with the meaning of kind of zero is very
negative
one is negative two is neutral three is
positive and four is very positive
i think this is fine but there are two
gotchas underlying this kind of scheme
first it's not really a fully ordered
scale in the sense that
four is stronger than three
but zero is stronger than one because we
have this kind of polarity split with
neutral in the center
so that's a kind of conceptual
difficulty and then the other part is
that by and large classifier models that
you pick will not give you partial
credit for being close we might hope
that a model that predicted a one
negative
uh was kind of right or certainly more
right if the true label is zero than a
model that had predicted four but of
course if these are all treated as
independent classification bins then
you'll get
you're just equally wrong no matter
which prediction you made relative to
the gold label and that seems kind of
unfair to our models
we are going to work with what i've
called the ternary problem i think this
is the minimal problem that really makes
sense conceptually for this one we group
zero and one into a negative category
three and four into a positive category
and remem reserve two as before for what
we're calling neutral
this kind of avoids the false
presupposition that every sentence is
either negative or positive because it
does allow us to make predictions into
this neutral or non-sentiment-laden
space
it's very common and you see this in the
paper as well as in a lot of work on the
sst to formulate this as a binary
problem for the binary problem we simply
remove the middle of the scale and treat
zero and one as negative and three and
four as positive as before i think that
has two drawbacks first we have to throw
away some data and second then we're
making this false presupposition that
every sentence is either classified as
negative or as positive when for a wide
range of cases in the world that might
be inappropriate
now i focus here on the root level
problem you can see that the numbers
here for train and dev are small and the
test set numbers are a little bit larger
than for devs so they're comparable
but we can also think of this as the all
nodes task because recall that a
hallmark feature of the sst is that
every single sub-constituent in these
examples has been labeled by crowd
workers so we could treat each one of
those as a kind of independent
classification problem we have the same
range for all of the values that they
can take on so we can do similar kind of
collapsing down into the ternary problem
or the binary problem and of course here
we have a much larger data set
for us
we're going to by and large work with
the data in one particular way which i
think is common in the literature as i
said we're going to have the ternary
formulation so our labels will be
positive negative and neutral
when we do the devin test step we're
going to test only on full examples so
for them we will not make predictions
into the sub-constituent space
and then as a default for the code as
you'll see it is set up to train only on
full examples so for these two cases nlu
is enlightening and not enlightening
here if those were two independent
sentences in the corpus we would train
just on those two independent examples
one negative labeled positive and the
other labeled negative
however you might imagine that you'll
get a lot more strength in training if
you also train on all the
sub-constituents which would mean
essentially expanding this example into
its full root version and all you is
enlightening but also all of the
sub-pieces that are captured and labeled
in corpus so that would give you many
more examples and much more diversity uh
and then of course not enlightening
would be split apart as well and then
you could decide for yourself in
addition whether you want to treat this
as two instances of enlightening or one
and the code facilitates all this you
can formulate it as a route only trading
scenario or as a sub-constituent
training scenario and you can keep or
remove duplicates
this is going to impact the amount of
computational resources that you need
for training models but of course bigger
could be better in this space because
you're just seeing much more
gold labeled information
so that's the overview and for much more
on this and how to work with our
distribution of the corpus and so forth
i would encourage you to work through
this note what could i have linked at
the bottom here